anush is playing a carnival game that
involves shooting two free throws the
table below displays the probability
distribution of x the number of shots
that anush makes in a set of two
attempts along with some summary
statistics
so here's the random variable x it's a
discrete random variable it only takes
on a finite number of values sometimes
people say it takes on a countable
number of values but we see he can
either make 0 free throws one or two of
the two
and the probability that he makes zero
is here one is here two is here and then
they also give us the mean of x and the
standard deviation of x
then they tell us if the game costs
anush fifteen dollars to play and he
wins ten dollars per shot he makes what
are the mean and standard deviation of
his net gain from playing the game n
right so let's define a new random
variable n which is equal to his net
gain
net gain
we can define n in terms of x what is
his net gain going to be
well let's see n
it's going to be equal to 10 times
however many shots he makes so it's
going to be 10
times x
and then no matter what he has to pay 15
dollars to play minus 15.
in fact we could set up a little table
here for the probability distribution of
n
so let me make it right over here
so i'll make it look just like this one
n is equal to
net
gain
and here we'll have the probability of n
and there's three outcomes here the
outcome that corresponds to him making 0
shots well that would be 10 times 0
minus 15 that would be a net gain of
negative 15 it would have the same
probability 0.16
the prob when he makes one shot the net
gain is going to be 10 times 1 minus 15
which is negative 5 but it's going to
have the same probability he has a 48
chance of making one shot and so it's a
48 chance of losing 5
and then last but not least
when x is 2 his net gain is going to be
positive 5 plus 5.
and so this is a 0.36
chance
so what they want us to figure out are
what are the mean and standard deviation
of his net gain so let's first figure
out the mean
of
n well if you scale a random variable
the corresponding mean is going to be
scaled by the same amount and if you
shift a random variable the
corresponding mean is going to be
shifted by the same amount so the mean
of n is going to be 10 times the mean of
x
minus 15
which is equal to 10 times 1.2 minus 15
this is 1.2 so it is 12
minus 15 which is equal to
negative 3. now the standard deviation
of n is going to be slightly different
for the standard deviation scaling
matters if you scale a random variable
by a certain value you would also scale
the standard deviation by the same value
so this is going to be equal to 10
times the standard deviation of x
now you might say what about the shift
over here well the shift should not
affect the spread of the random variable
if you're scaling the random variable
well your spread should grow by the
amount that you're scaling it but by
shifting it it doesn't affect how much
you disperse from the mean
so standard deviation is only affected
by the scaling but not by the shifting
here so this is going to be 10 times
0.69 which is going to this was an
approximation so i'll say this is
approximately equal to
6.9 so this is our new distribution for
our net gain
this is the mean of our net gain and
this is roughly the standard deviation
of our net gain